the Great and the good together today to
commemorate the long path to peace is
this a moment to celebrate prime
minister
leaders gather in to Mark a deal struck
25 years ago Madam president your
message to the dup bringing peace but
not political stability Northern
Ireland's assembly still stored now of
course we meet here today in
circumstances that are far from perfect
we must keep working to persuade all
parts of the community that returning to
the institutions is the best path
and we will do that Northern Ireland's
Secretary of State confident storm will
be backed by the year end yeah I'm a
glass half full guy and yes I truly
believe that and I actually believe that
their leadership would love that to
happen too but I think that there's a
process to take the whole unionist
Community with them which is vitally
important for peace and stability and
prosperity moving forward
early evening and political leaders of
then and now gathering for Gala dinner
at Hillsborough Castle to celebrate this
anniversary and consider what comes next
if there is one message from this Hall
tonight one message from the people of
Northern Ireland to the world it is
surely this we will never go back
instead instead we will learn the
lessons of 25 years ago we will keep
working keep moving forward bringing
everyone with us 25 years ago
this
agreement only happened
because
leaders were prepared to put their
leadership in Peril for the good of
their people inside Hills for Castle
tonight The Architects of the Good
Friday agreement and its beneficiaries
commemorate an historic deal that
brought last in peace to Northern
Ireland but even as past political
leaders celebrate their achievements the
current crop are acutely aware that they
are not delivering for people here with
power sharing at Stormont still stalled
and no solution in sight the labor
leader urging the PM to help hasten the
restoration of power over here the
government has not played that honest
broker role in the way that I think they
should have done now obviously the
protocol is a step in the right
direction we supported it and voted for
it and I hope that that window of
opportunity to get the institutions back
up is there but it will be a matter for
the parties here in Northern Ireland the
role of the UK government is to be that
honest broker those who brokered the
deal now look to their successors to
protect that Legacy the first step is
getting storm at working again the
harder Journey will be keeping it that
way
whatever